Your brain thinks your future self is
literally a different person. That's why
you procrastinate. You're not lazy.
You're making logical decisions to let
some stranger deal with it. But here's
the uncomfortable truth. Motivation
isn't the answer. It's just mental
marketing. All hype. No operations. The
real secret? Successful people are
actually the laziest. They just
automated everything important. They're
too lazy to fail.
Let me hit you with math that will break
your brain. Small daily improvements
don't add up. They multiply into
something terrifying.
By year's end, you're not slightly
better. You're unrecognizable.
Your environment makes 43% of your
decisions while you take full credit.
Your room isn't where you live. It's
your external brain making garbage
decisions. Want to make success
inevitable?
Watch the full video. Your dreams are
about to become a system.